810 747 162 8 188 200
[Musique]
c'est le chiffre que je perds sur un an
ça correspond à ce que
monsieur macron va m'enlever pour toute
une année avec la csg 762 euros c'est la
somme que je vais perdre cette année sur
ma retraite en 2018
mon budget gazole va augmenter de 200
euros ces chiffres c'est l'addition
macro et malheureusement ce sont les
français qui la paye depuis le 1er
janvier dernier
depuis son élection en mai 2010 est
emmanuel macron à instaurer huit
nouvelles taxes ou impôts en plus de
toutes celles qui ont augmenté ce sont
4,5 milliards d'euros de prélèvements
supplémentaires sur les retraités sur
les ménages sur les actifs l'addition
macro ce sont 8 millions de français qui
depuis le 1er janvier 2018 vont subir
une hausse de la csg de près de 25% des
français qui ont cotisé toute leur vie
et qu'ils sont considérés par ce
gouvernement comme des gens aisés
un couple de retraités qui perçoit
chacun 1000 euros net par mois verra une
hausse de 444 euros de la csg chaque
année je pense que c'est absolument
énorme comme
comme perte de 2 pouvoir d'achat ça va
être très difficile à compenser je vis
seul donc j'ai tout à payer ça
représente plus de 10 k 10 pour l'année
le remplacement de ma machine à laver de
mon frigo qui sont défaillants
actuellement c'est quelqu'un de
totalement injuste et retraités sont les
premières victimes des augmentations
d'impôts on ne peut pas faire 40 % des
cadeaux fiscaux cette année aux 5 % des
plus riches et augmenter massivement la
cg les retraités ne sont pas des
privilégiés
ils ont souvent travaillé dur ils n'ont
pas volé leur retraite
elle est le fruit d'une vie de travail
j'étais conducteur de taxi et c'est un
métier où l'on commence très bonne heure
en fini très tard c'est des journées de
10 11 heures par jour et sandy est
souvent le dimanche je ne faisais pas 35
heures j'ai été jusqu'à 45 eur et plus
c'est inadmissible comme prennent de
l'argent sur ma retraite je pense que
j'ai quand même beaucoup travaillé je
suis allé manifester il y avait vraiment
des gens malheureux les retraités en
colère je déplore que monsieur macron
oppose les français
on a d'un côté la jeunesse et de l'autre
côté les retraités avec emmanuel macron
on ne peut plus aider nos enfants nos
petits enfants
il n'y a plus de solidarité entre les
générations
franchement ça suffit l'addition macron
c'est aussi la france rurale et
périphériques qui est sans cesse prise
pour cible avec une mesure emblématique
celle de la hausse du prix des
carburants et notamment du gasoil
prendre sa voiture n'est pas toujours un
choix pour aller se ravitailler ou aller
chez le médecin
bien souvent nous n'avons que ce moyen
de locomotion on pourrait aussi parler
du coût du contrôle technique qui se
trouve renchérie l'addition macron ce
sont aussi des attaques envers notre
politique familiale qui est détricoter
et des petits épargnants qui sont pris
pour cibles les républicains sont aux
côtés des français pour défendre leur
pouvoir d'achat
nous avons plusieurs propositions fortes
d'abord en luttant contre le gaspillage
de la dépense publique qui a augmenté de
7,3 milliards d'euros avec le
gouvernement dément
macron et qui n'a pas fait des efforts
suffisants pour diminuer le nombre de
fonctionnaires
c'est aussi une règle d'or zeroes
d'impôts enfin nous souhaitons le
rétablissement de la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires une mesure dont
avait bénéficié 9 millions de français
emmanuel macron son gouvernement ne
comprennent pas la réalité de la vie
dans nos territoires et pire même ils
méprisent leurs habitants cette majorité
silencieuse qui ne se plaint jamais et
pourtant porte fièrement les valeurs de
notre beau pays
[Musique]